مرحبًا ، أنا دانا سانتوس
، مدربة للتنفس والجسم في الرياضات الاحترافية
عندما تختار الدمبل
لممارسة التمارين ، قد يكون من الصعب
معرفة الوزن المناسب لك ،
إليك بعض الطرق لتعرف أي
الدمبل  يجب أن تستخدم الوزن
الذي تختاره في البداية سيعتمد على
مستوى لياقتك الحالي ،
لذا ربما كنت تمارس الرياضة
وأخذت استراحة
وتعود أو ربما تكون مبتدئًا في كلتا
الحالتين.  سوف تبدأ بوزن أخف
وبعد ذلك
سترتفع تدريجياً إلى أوزان أثقل حيث
يسمح جسمك بما هي أهدافك ، هل
تبحث عن صحة
القلب والأوعية الدموية بشكل عام ، هل تتطلع إلى
بناء كتلة عضلية بشكل واضح إذا
كنت ترغب في بناء العضلات
سوف تحتاج إلى استخدام وزن أثقل ،
ولكن إذا
كنت تريد صحة القلب والأوعية الدموية بشكل عام ، فستقوم
بعمل ممثلين أعلى بوزن أخف
ولكن هذا يعتمد أيضًا على أجزاء الجسم
التي تعمل عليها.  لدينا عضلات أكبر
في الجزء السفلي من الجسم ، لذا إذا كنت تقوم
بتمارين الجزء السفلي من الجسم مثل القرفصاء
والكؤوس التي تعمل على ساقيك ، فستحتاج إلى
تحديد وزن أثقل مثل هذا
15 أو ربما هذا 10 أو شيء أخف
سيعمل بشكل أفضل  الجزء العلوي من الجسم
مثل الضغط فوق الرأس أو تموجات العضلة ذات الرأسين هي
أكبر مؤشر على ما إذا كنت
تستخدم الوزن المناسب أم لا هو الشكل الخاص بك
إذا كنت تواجه مشكلة في إكمال
التكرارات القليلة الماضية ، لذلك دعنا نقول أنك تقوم
بستة إلى ثماني ممثلين لأنك  في
محاولة لبناء كتلة عضلية وستة وسبعة
وثمانية ، تبدأ في تأرجح جسمك ، دعنا
نقول إذا كان ذلك هو تجعيد العضلة ذات الرأسين أو تقوس
ظهرك ، فأنت تستخدم مجموعات عضلية أخرى
لتعويض جسدك الذي يخبرك أن هذا
الوزن ثقيل جدًا بالنسبة لك ، لذا استخدم
كمقياس لمساعدتك في
تحديد الوزن المناسب لك